they've held out for months but they
can't anymore this war is getting worse
by the day and they're fleeing
we've seen the chaotic movement of
millions from ukraine but here in the
east in donbass the slow creeper
fighting in village after village and
town after town is forcing thousands
more to uproot and leave with everything
lost
this is a train station in pacroffs it's
the last exit point
every day an evacuation train leaves at
4 30 for the west the most needy are
loaded on first
volunteers risk their lives to pluck the
old and infirm from their homes usually
under
[Music]
fire katarina bednenko is now immobile
she's had a stroke
as the fighting english intensified she
and her husband mikola had to wait to be
rescued
it's the first time they've been outside
since february
just getting here is a mission
seventy-eight-year-old valentina volkova
went to the market under fire and gave
up on going home she kept walking two
and a half kilometers and took the first
taxi out
she's left her life behind
us
these were the believers in the safety
of the support promised by the west
but they're from the towns now on fire
hundreds and hundreds are coming out
every single day
and they're the people who are coming
from the
front line
cities that they literally can't stay in
anymore
the elderly being firmer are put on
board and the rest of families to say
they've literally that's all they've
left their homes with a few bags
and this is going on every single day
and there's a very big likelihood it's
going to get worse
ludmilla and her son are on board but
they don't have a clue what their future
is they've got the ride they didn't want
it's just plain heartbreaking
there's no sign of a let up in this war
in the east it's intensifying
the 430 express from the cross is their
lifeline out
they're safe for now but they're still
helpless like so many others
[Music]
joe ramsey sky news in the donbass